mais nous devons regarder ici au canada
ah parce qu'on a beaucoup de travail à
faire a même si on regarde notre
histoire avec les peuples autochtones
nous savons qu on doit faire mieux
[Musique]
du point ce qu'on a fait beaucoup de
près dans la première année mais ce qui
est clair c'est la portance du
portefeuille qui inclut la diversité et
l'exclusion et la rudesse du canada
parce que aucun de la diversité a
toujours été l'une de nos plus grandes
forces
on doit continuer à travailler tôt
toujours être là pour travailler faire
notre meilleur
donc c'est une des façons d'assurer qu'
on a toujours une voix aux tables du
cabinet
[Musique]
il reste beaucoup à accomplir mais on a
déjà commencé le travail sur le ghana le
secteur hier de lutte contre le racisme
on a commencé par créer une stratégie
partie de la stratégie était d'avoir une
investissement de 45 millions de dettes
du dollar qui exclut de cette feria et
on appelle l investissement de 15
millions de dollars pour 85 projets un
d'une côte à l'autre au canada
donc je pense que on continue de
travailler là et le secrétariat créé de
façon d'assurer que les voix des
communautés diverses du canada continue
de nous informer avec les politiques la
politique qui est nécessaire
on a aussi un sondage que les
communautés lgbt q2 et c'est parce que
une des choses dans molette de mandat et
d'avoir un plan d'action pour les
communautés lgbt coup dur qui vont
informer le gouvernement national et on
a une politique de jeunesse de la
jeunesse canadienne
donc maintenant on a des consultations
pour assurer que nous savons ce que être
importante pour les jeunes
nous savons que le racisme système qui
existe au canada le premier ministre l'a
dit à mes seins des façons comprends tu
penses créer un canada qui est meilleure
et plus et fizi et d'assurer contre un
fait les décisions par l'évidence car
l'information qui est partagé avec nous
dès qu'ils me loger donc les 85 projets
et que j'ai mentionnés c'est parti de la
deuxième a appuyé de notre stratégie
la première c'est d'avoir le leadership
au gouvernement fédéral
la deuxième c'est d'assurer que les
communautés et le soir les
investissements pour qu'il puisse faire
à partir de la solution mais cumulé 10
avr ce qui marche ce qui fonctionne et
il ne fonctionne pas donc le
gouvernement va travailler en
partenariat avec les autres et puis la
troisième puis essayer d'assurer contrat
de l'éducation pour changer les
habitudes parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ne connaît pas qui au
canada
nous avons une stratégie de lutte contre
le racisme parce que le racisme existe
au canada
donc on prend du temps de regarder les
autres pays ce qui ce qui se passe aux
autres pays mais nous devons regarder
ici au canada parce qu'on a beaucoup de
travail à faire mm et si on regarde la
nature histoire avec les peuples
autochtones
nous savons qu on doit faire mieux et
nous avons une stabilité et d'avoir eu
ministre aux travaux du cabinet est une
autre façon d'assurer que nos décisions
absurdes bien crie parce que nous serons
plus accessible
[Musique]
on a avancé plusieurs problèmes avec un
s&p investissement de 9 milliards de
dollars
parce qu'une formation que les jeunes il
ils ont des gars cité de besoin donc il
ya quatre jeunes qui sont un à l'école
donc ils ont les dépenses comme il doit
faire le rendu il doit pas être pris
pour l'école et les classes donc on a
avancé le can am heure 6-1 mais il y
avait aussi plusieurs des gens qui ont
dit on veut continuer à travailler avec
les theresa rodgers problème on a changé
la façon qu'il fonctionne parce que
c'est toujours un problème pour l'été
pour que les yeux ne pouvait avoir une
emplois dans l'été mais avec la pandémie
on a fait changer les choses ont
commencé on a dit que vous pouvez avoir
des opportunités de l'emploi de l'été
jusqu'au fameux février 2021 et on l'a
aussi dire petites entreprises si vous
pouvez créer un emploi pour les jeunes
nous allons vous donner 100%
renversement aussi pour que ces
opportunités pour exister
donc ces deux choses comme ça avec les
canadiens longue on a augmenté le
montant de brett que les jeunes ne
soient pas ce qu'on ne doit pas payer le
bret
mais on doit le premier de longues et on
a aussi dit qu'on ne doit pas payer pour
six mois et puis on a arrêté le entre
choisi pour 6 mois donc lire plusieurs
problèmes honneur on a fait des
investissements pour assurer qu'on
réponde aux diversité des besoins des
jeunes y inclus les entrepreneurs le
futur bonheur c'est un problème national
et les jeunes qui ont dit nous voulons
créer notre propre en poils comme
entrepreneur on a augmenté les
investissements profitent championnat
donc il ya une longue liste chose qu'on
a fait mais ce qui reste un mal si on a
beaucoup de travail a continué à faire
parce que notre gouvernement a toujours
répondra aux besoins des jeunes nous
savons qu'ils ne sont pas seulement les
leaders de demain
ils sont les leaders d'aujourd'hui et
plusieurs jeunes étaient là à 1 pendant
tout la pandémie à répandre des besoins
de la communauté et de leur famille